I don't come to you today as an expert I
come to you as someone who has been
really interested in how I get better at
what I do and how we all do I think it's
not just how good you are now I think
it's how good you're gonna be that
really matters I was visiting this Birth
Center in the north of India I was
watching the birth attendants and I
realized I was witnessing in them in
extreme form this very struggle which is
how people improve in the face of
complexity or don't the women here are
delivering in a region where the typical
birth center has a 1 in 20 death rate
for the babies and the moms were dying
at a rate 10 times higher than they do
elsewhere now we've known the critical
practices that stopped the big killers
in birth for decades and the thing about
it is that even in this place in this
place especially the simplest things are
not simple we know for example you
should wash hands and put on clean
gloves but here the tap is in another
room and they don't have clean gloves to
reuse their gloves they wash them in
this basin of dilute bleach but you can
see there's still blood on the gloves
from the last delivery 10 percent of
babies are born with difficulty
breathing
everywhere we know what to do you dry
the baby with a clean cloth to stimulate
them to breathe if they don't start to
breathe you give them you suction out
their Airways and if that doesn't work
you give them breaths with the baby mask
but these are skills that they've
learned mostly from textbooks and that
baby mask is broken
in this one disturbing image for me is
is a picture that brings home just how
dire the situation is this is a baby ten
minutes after birth and he's alive but
only just no clean cloth has not been
dried not warming skin-to-skin an
unsterile clamp across the cord
he's an infection waiting to happen and
he's losing his temperature by the
minute
successful child delivery requires a
successful team of people whole team has
to be skilled and coordinated the nurses
who do the deliveries in a place like
this the doctor who backs them up the
supply clerk who's responsible for 22
critical drugs and supplies being in
stock and at the bedside the medical
officer in charge responsible for the
quality of the whole facility the thing
is is they they are all experienced
professionals I didn't meet anybody who
hadn't been part of thousands of
deliveries but against the complexities
that they face they seem to be at their
limits they were not getting better
anymore
it's how good you're gonna be that
really matters it presses on a
fundamental question how do
professionals get better what they do
how do they get great and there are two
views about this one is the traditional
pedagogical view that is that you go to
school you study you practice you learn
you graduate and then you go out into
the world and you make your way on your
own a professional is someone who is
capable of managing their own
improvement that is the approach that
virtually all professionals have learned
by that's how doctors learn that's how
lawyers do scientists musicians and the
thing is it works consider for example
the legendary Julliard violin instructor
Dorothy delay she trained in a
Rossler violin virtuosos Midori ceratin
Itzhak Perlman each of them came to her
as young talents and they worked with
her over years what she worked on most
she said was inculcating in them habits
of thinking and of learning so that they
could make their way in the world
without her when they were done now the
contrasting view comes out of sports and
they say you are never done everybody
needs a coach everyone the greatest in
the world needs a coach so I tried to
think about this as a surgeon pay
someone to come into my operating room
observe me and critique me it seems
absurd expertise means not needing to be
coached so then which view is right I
learned that coaching came into sports
as a very American idea in 1875 Harvard
and Yale played one of the very first
American Rules Football games
Yale hired a head coach Harvard did not
the results over the next three decades
Harvard won just four times
Harvard hired a coach and it became the
way that sports works but isn't
necessary then does it transfer into
other fields I decided to ask of all
people you talk Perlman he had trained
the Dorothy delay way and became
arguably the greatest violinist of his
generation one of the beautiful things
about getting to write for The New
Yorker as I call people up and they
return my phone calls and Perlman
returned my phone call so we ended up
having an almost two-hour conversation
about how he got to where he got in his
career and I asked him I said why don't
violate us have coaches
and he said I don't know but I always
had a coach you always had a coach oh
yeah
my wife Toby they had graduated together
from Juilliard and she had given up her
job as a concert violinist to be his
coach sitting in the audience observing
him and giving him feedback he talked in
that middle section you know you sounded
a little bit mechanical what can you do
differently next time
it was crucial to everything he became
he said turns out there are numerous
problems in making it on your own you
don't recognize the issues that are
standing in your way or if you do you
don't necessarily know how to fix them
and the result is that somewhere along
the way you stopped improving and I
thought about that and I realized that
was exactly what had happened to me as a
surgeon I'd entered practice in 2003 and
for the first several years it was just
the steady upward improvement in my
learning curve
I watched my complication rates drop
from one year to the next and after
about five years they leveled out and a
few more years after that I realized I
wasn't getting a better anymore and I
thought is this as good as I'm gonna get
so I thought a little more and I said
okay I'll try a coach so I asked a
former professor of mine who had retired
his name is Bob Osteen and he agreed to
come to my operating room and observe me
the case I remember that first case it
went beautifully I didn't think there
would be anything much you'd have to say
when we were done instead he had all
page of dense with notes just small
things he said but it's the small things
that matter did you notice that the
light had swung out of the wound during
the case we spent about half an hour
just operating off the light from
reflected surfaces
another thing I noticed you said your
elbow goes up in the air every once in a
while that means you're not in full
control a surgeon's elbow should be down
at their sides resting comfortably so
that means if you feel your elbow going
in the air you should get a different
instrument or just move your feet it was
a whole nother level of awareness and I
had to think you know there was
something fundamentally profound about
this he was describing what great
coaches do and what they do is they are
your external eyes and ears providing a
more accurate picture of your reality
they're recognizing the fundamentals
they're breaking your actions down and
then helping you build them back up
again after two months of coaching I
felt myself getting better again and
after a year I saw my complications
dropped down even further it was painful
I didn't like being observed and at
times I didn't want to have to work on
things I also felt there are periods
where I would get worse before I got
better but it made me realize that the
coaches were on to something profoundly
important in my other work I lead a
Health Systems Innovation Center called
the Ariadne labs where we work on
problems in the delivery of health care
including global child births as part of
it we had worked with the World Health
Organization to devise a safe childbirth
checklist it lays out the fundamentals
it breaks down the fundamentals the
critical actions that a team needs to go
through when a woman comes in and labor
when she's ready to push when the baby
is out and then when the mom and baby
are ready to go home and we knew that
just handing out a checklist wasn't
going to change very much and even just
teaching it in the classroom wasn't
necessarily going to be enough to get
people to make the changes that you
needed to bring it alive and I thought
on my experience and and said what if we
tried coaching what if we tried coaching
massive scale we found some incredible
partners including the government of
India and we ran a trial there in 120
birth centers in Uttar Pradesh in
India's largest state half of the
centres got half the centers basically
we just observed but the other half got
visits from coaches we trained an army
of doctors and nurses like this one who
learned to observe the care and and also
the managers and then help them build on
their strengths and address their
weaknesses one of the skills for example
they had to work on with people turned
out to be fundamentally important was
communication getting the nurses to
practice speaking up when the baby mask
is broken or the gloves are not in stock
or someone's not washing their hands and
then getting others including the
managers to practice listening this
small army of coaches ended up coaching
400 nurses and other birth attendants
and a hundred physicians and managers we
tracked the results across a hundred and
sixty thousand births the results in the
control group you had and these were
ones who did not get coaching they
delivered on only 1/3 of 18 basic
practices that we were measuring and
most important was over the course of
the years of study we saw no improvement
over time the other folks got four
months of coaching and then a tapered
off over eight months and we saw them
increase to greater than two-thirds of
the practices being delivered and worked
we could see the improvement in quality
and you could see it happen across a
whole range of centers have suggested
that coaching could be a whole line of
way that we bring value to what we do
that this you can imagine the whole kind
of job category that could reach out in
the world and that millions of people
could fulfill we were clearly at the
beginning of it though because there was
still a distance to go you have to put
all of the checklist together to achieve
them at the substantial reductions in
mortality but we began seeing the first
places that we're getting there and this
Center was one of them because coaching
helped them learn to execute on the
fundamentals and you could see it here
this is a 23 year old woman who had come
in by ambulance in labor with her third
child
she broke her water her water broke in
the in the triage area so they brought
her directly to the labor and delivery
room and then they ran through their
checks I put the time stamp on here
so you could see how quickly all of this
happens and how much more complicated
that makes things within four minutes
they had taken the blood pressure
measured her pulse and also measured the
heart rate of the baby that meant that
the blood pressure cuff and the fetal
doppler monitor they were all there and
the nurse howdy knew how to use it
the tema was skilled and coordinated the
mom was doing great the baby's heart was
143 which is normal eight minutes later
the intensity of the contractions picked
up so the nurse washed her hands put on
clean gloves examined her and found that
her cervix was fully dilated
the baby was ready to come she then went
straight over to do her next set of
checks all of the equipment she worked
her way through and made sure she had
everything she needed at the bedside the
baby mask was there the sterile towel
the sterile equipment that you needed
and then three minutes later one push
and that baby was out
I was watching this delivery and
suddenly I realized that the mood in
that room had changed the nurse was
looking at the community health worker
who'd come in with the woman because
that baby did not seem to be alive she
was blue and floppy and not breathing
she would be one of that one in 20 but
the nurse kept going with her
checkpoints she dried that baby with a
clean towel and after a minute when that
didn't stimulate that baby she ran to
get the baby mask and the other one went
to get the suction she didn't have a
mechanical section because you couldn't
count on electricity so she used a mouth
suction and within 20 seconds she was
clearing out that that little girl's
Airways and she got back a green thick
liquid and within a minute of being able
to do that and suctioning out over and
over that baby started to breathe
another minute and that baby was crying
and five minutes after that she was pink
and warming on her mother's chest and
that mother reached out to grab that
nurses hand and they could all breathe I
saw a team transformed because of
coaching and I saw at least one life
saved because of it we followed up with
that mother a few months later mom and
baby were doing great the baby's name is
on chica it means beautiful and she is
what's possible when we really
understand how people get better at what
they do thank you
[Applause]
[Music]